you're going to write the code to make
the create conference method create and
save conference entities but first I
want to point out how creating
conference entities is different in a
way than creating profile entity for
profile entities we specifically use the
unique user ID as the ID for the entity
key for conferences though we really
don't care what the key is so we're
going to let App Engine allocate it for
us so here's the code to let App Engine
allocate the key you use the factory dot
allocate ID method and in the simplest
case you just provide the entity class
so that would be recipe conference
profile whatever so for example to
allocate an ID to a conference entity
you specify the key type as conference
and you specify conference class but
this isn't quite right actually though
one more thing we need to do is to take
account of the fact the conference has a
parent which is a profile entity of the
user who created it so when you want to
allocate an ID to an entity that has a
parent when you call the allocate ID
method you need to specify the parent
key that's the first argument so here's
the code you need to write to allocate
an ID to a conference entity you need to
specify the profile key for the ancestor
and specify the conference class another
thing to mention is that you've already
learned how to save an entity by calling
off e dot save but in this case when you
save your conferences you also need to
save the profile entity you can just use
the entities function IES the pluralized
version and specify the list of
comma-separated entities to save you
should have already copied the skeleton
version of the create conference method
into the conference API class but if you
haven't go ahead and do it now you see
that it's full of two do's you're going
to go ahead and implement each of these
two do's first of all you need to get
the user ID of the logged in user then
you're going to get the key of the
user's profile and you're going to
allocate a key for the conference and
don't forget the conference has a parent
so you need to take that into
consideration when allocating the ID for
the key you're going to get the ID of
the conference entity then you actually
need to see if the profile entity
corresponding to the
phile that's the parent of the
conference actually exists if it does
get it out of the data store if it
doesn't go ahead and create a new one
using the default values for the profile
properties and then finally you actually
create the conference then you need to
save both the conference and the profile
entities and return the profile the
reason you need to save both the
conference and the profile entities is
even though if you've got the existing
profile out of the datastore you haven't
made any changes to it if the profile
didn't already exist you will have
created a new one so you will need to
save it so go ahead and fill in the two
dues in create conference you already
copied over the skeleton version of it
and now you can write the code in the
two dues when you've implemented create
conference you can run your app on
localhost and then go ahead and create a
conference or two and you can use the
API Explorer or you can use the create
conference page in the web UI and then
check your conference entities in the
datastore viewer in the admin console to
make sure that they got created as you
expected now at this point you actually
can use the create a conference page in
the web UI for the app because when you
submit this form it sends a call to the
create conference function and you've
actually implemented that now so using
this form should let you create
conferences and it's kind of a nice easy
thing to do all you need to do is
specify the name and all the other
values will default however at this
point you can't use the show conferences
to check that the conference got created
because you haven't yet implemented the
function that provides the behavior of
the show conference page so no matter
whether you create a conference in the
api's explorer or the create conference
page in the web UI you'll need to use
the data store viewer in the admin
console to check that the conference got
created after you've created some
conferences go ahead and look at them in
the datastore view of the admin console
and see if you can figure out which
properties are indexed check all that
apply